hey guys what's up this is andrew for
trendsenses.com so i'm here guys to make
a full analysis on the bitcoin there are
a lot of things happening there
different scenarios that might take
place some of them are a bit scary some
of them are much better so let's check
everything that we have here and let's
try to see what can happen next let's
get into it
[Music]
alright guys so bam bitcoin i'm gonna
start okay let's start from this weekly
chart let's analyze first this move that
we have here so i'm gonna start you're
gonna see i'm gonna jump from the
logarithmic scale to the regular scale
because you're gonna see that we need
both for to analyze uh the bitcoin so
here first we can try to make some
elliot wave counting
so let me remove this one we do some
elite 12 counting since march 19 alright
and we try to see if the move down that
we're seeing right now is a correction
of the move that started in 2019 or if
it's even longer correction
or
if it's just a small correction of this
move that is not finished yet
so three different scenarios i'm gonna
start with uh the scenario that i've
been showing you guys for quite some
time so in 2019 we started the first
wave we were at three thousand one
two right abc
three with five waves quite clear one
two three four five then force wave that
started in april 21 guys last year we
corrected quite strongly from 65 000 to
30 000. and
then i was expecting a fifth wave to
come which
happened and the question is is this
fifth wave complete first
so to answer that question i will try to
see if there are five waves inside my
fixed wave so if here i have a force
wave
okay the first wave will be here and
here one two three four five all right
and but let's be honest look at that
guys this fifth wave that ends up at 68
000 roughly 69 000 the highest level was
69
thousands let's see if it respects fib
ratios because this is the only thing we
can do to know if the wave is complete
or not does it i mean fit with what we
usually see for fifth wave so to answer
that we're gonna measure one plus three
we applied to the bottom of the fourth
as usual guys and we check if we arrive
to the golden number ratios and here
we actually do because the 61.8 percent
fib projections was at
i have here 66 000 but you know
depending on how you apply this wave
so roughly 66 thousand so went to 69 000
so so actually even is this if this
fifth wave looks short it is
i mean it is respecting fib ratios
somehow because you you know guess that
fifth wave they go to the 61.8 or one
point six one eight or one to one right
so we could have gone to hundred and
thirty thousand it was actually my
scenario i thought we would go there
right away because you know but we had
some bad news coming on the global
market and some bad news coming on the
crypto market as well so for this reason
the the fifth wave was actually shorter
than expected but it's still a fifth
wave alright so right now
in this scenario
it means that we are actually
correcting
guys okay so then if this fifth wave is
complete here one two three four five
and guys if i zoom out because we need
to really understand where we are guys
what happened for the past 10 years on
the bitcoin on the cryptocurrency market
guys it was a 10 year rally i mean yeah
nine year rally all right one two three
four five and even here we can try to
see if this fifth wave that might be
it's a primary cycle guys it's very you
know i'm here doing technical analysis
on a very long period of time
but
it's important to understand what you
know is really happening on this market
and what can happen
next so i measure one plus three applied
to the bottom of the force i'm here just
checking if the ratios are respected all
right and here you know the fifth wave
where when roughly to do 3.618 alright
so definitely
this fixed wave is valid it's long
enough to be considered as a valid fifth
wave and so a correction might be taking
place so if we are in this situation we
can check how long uh so if we're
correcting this entire move guys we
would need around minimum one or two
years of correction right so this is the
first scenario i'm not saying it's my
preferred scenario it's just one
scenario i'm going to show you the two
other scenarios very soon so in this
case first how deep do we need to
correct to answer that question you take
fibs and usually
we don't go below the sixty one point
eight percent retracement so i measured
the entire move up guys the entire
movement for the past nine years and the
61.8 is at 27 000 all right so not that
low
so first
thing if we are correcting this entire
move up uh we would probably go to the
61.8 we have 20 000 so maybe 20 000 all
right i'm here talking about the
correction that would last one or two
years so
in the next year or two years
bitcoin to me cannot go below 20 000 it
can go to 27 000 okay so first
information if we see bitcoin
between 20 and 30 it's a buy right
then
this is the first scenario and once
again this scenario would have actually
this would mean let me get rid of the
field protections it would mean that we
are doing a wave all right and that a b
wave is to come okay
and then a c wave so maybe the c wave
would go to 29
26 27 i don't know all right this would
be one year
so in any case
okay we can do a flat all right if we do
a flat we can maybe even go right now to
29 000 it's possible okay now if i
zoom a little bit more i'm gonna do it
i'm frame now
we are trying to see so now i need to
switch to regular scale because you can
see guys this trend line is not fitting
well right
it's full of fake out if you go on a
regular
scale it's perfect all right so this is
a tip that you can use guys to know if
you need to use the log at the regular
scale and on bitcoin for the very long
term moves uh your logarithmic scale is
much better gives you better breakouts
but for short-term moves like this one
even if it's sharp and we're talking
about 50 correction the regular scale is
the one that everybody is looking at so
it's the one that should be used so here
if it's a wave a waves usually develop
in in five waves one two three four five
all right and this fifth wave should
develop in five webs as well so
one two three four five okay it might be
finished okay
it's not easy to say
what i can tell you is that 40 000 is
resistance
if we break it it would probably be the
end of the a wave we would start in this
scenario a b wave
that could go to the 52 000 level
roughly you know the top of the force
something like this
in terms of fibs you see 50 61.8 around
50 55 i would say 52 this is my level if
i see bitcoin at 52 i would sell
everything i have but for now we're
still in the airwave so the airwave
might also go lower so right now i think
that buying the deep now is not uh the
best thing to do buying the dip around
30 000 is great i will do that
personally okay if i see bitcoin here i
will buy the dip and if we have a
breakout
and we test
i would probably buy as well here yeah
and then i would be a seller around 50
to thousands so this is for the first
scenario
and if we break 30 000 it's still a good
buy because we've seen that even if
we're in the very long term correction
going below 27 000
is unlikely
we could go to 20 but this would
probably happen in the c wave that would
happen in six months not right now i
mean this is what i believe okay so we
have completed this first scenario and
we
might have a b wave coming soon and the
level to watch is 40 000 right now but
it's a downward sloping trend line so
it's going to be lower every time so not
doing anything makes this level going
lower with time which gives you a better
entry if you wait for a breakout so
that's why right now i don't think it's
good to buy it's better to wait
then the alternative scenario guys
look
there's something else so let me go back
on the log scale bam
okay the alternative scenario is that
actually this fifth wave is not complete
this is not an abc
and look the second wave here in yellow
it was quite long right we're talking
about
nine months and here my first wave is
very short in time all right it's deep
but it's short in time so what if
the fifth wave is to come and this is a
massive
flat correction
okay
this could very well be a massive abc so
the b wave is slightly higher than the
beginning of the air wave but why not
maybe we are in an abc and then we would
have a fifth wave and where would go the
fifth wave we use fib projections once
again so we've done that before right
and we've seen the targets so this is
the alternative scenario maybe the
larger degrees wave is not complete and
we're talking about once again we find
the usual levels i was talking about
before
five thousand hundred thirty thousand
okay so those are the levels if the
fifth wave of the fifth wave is only to
come and if this is the case the only
difference we would still have a
breakout above forty thousand we would
still go higher but we would go higher
doing five waves okay we would do five
waves up so something like this so we
would still have a breakout re-test and
then push higher the difference is that
we would go much higher and we would
make new high so the question you might
have
is how am i supposed to know if we are
doing a b wave and that then we get
brutally rejected and go maybe to the 27
area or if we are doing a one two three
four five that's the question that i
think is not easy to answer right now
but we have some hints that we can use
look
we are wondering if it's a b wave coming
or a first wave this wave of a larger
degree
bullish development so to answer that
question let's check the b waves we had
in the past because we have here b wave
here a v wave here a potential b wave as
well and look guys and here we have a
one okay let me do the ones because we
are wondering if
the breakout above 4d would be a first
wave or if it would be a b wave so let's
compare guys we have different
indicators we can use we're going to use
volume and we're going to use momentum
and volatility by the way i'm making a
cause guys where actually i use these
indicators a lot and i'm giving you a
full step-by-step method to know when
the momentum is telling you that a
breakout would be successful same thing
for the volume and same thing for the
volatility so it's gonna be like really
really amazing i'm very excited i will
it's going to be really soon soon i will
let you know guys but this is the method
that i'm going to apply here so
we are
wondering once again let me just quickly
sum up the situation we're wondering if
we are in this scenario that a rebound
will take place soon whatever happens
maybe lower maybe now i don't know but
the rebound will happen and we don't
know if it's going to be a b wave or a
first wave so we compare the b waves
here and here so first thing let's check
the volume all right so let me add a
vertical line so we can follow okay so
look at the volume between
here so the volume is here guys so
big volume during the a wave
and then the b wave d had a small volume
increase okay here true during this
breakout
but not that amazing okay let's check
the second b wave we have
so this one
look at the volume
increase i agree during this breakout
above the 20-week moving average all
right here those two balls
but not incredible now let's check the
first waves how do they happen with
volume so this is the first wave okay so
bam look look this bar
much bigger
than what we have here okay much bigger
this is a substantial volume increase
that happened after a very low volume
now let's check this first wave same
thing guys look at that look at this
first wave so the difference between the
first wave and a b wave is first uh we
can just check the recent past and we
can see right away the volume involved
is much greater and then the third wave
they of course have the even bigger
volumes this is the third wave it's the
highest green bars that i traded all
right that traded during the third waves
as you can you guys know they are the
most impulsive and the strongest ones so
first if we see
low volume coming on this breakout when
i say low volume look at the volume it's
already very low so if we have a small
volume increase it would probably be a b
wave it would be a trap guys
but if we have something really really
big like this one so you need to compare
for example to july 20 then it would
probably be a first wave okay so then we
would enter on the pullback on the
second wave this would be the trade to
do okay if we have really a big volume
then what else we can check we can check
the momentum so to check the momentum we
can use uh divergences but i don't want
to go into that in this video because it
would take too much time but we can
check just simply the moving averages so
you can see
this b wave went through
all right the 20 week moving average
this one too but just one week then it
got rejected so this one was really a
bigger trap but the volume could have
tell us that uh this was not a good
breakout
and here we're not even
above okay
i mean in this little b wave so
being above the 20-week moving average
is not a guarantee of a successful
breakout but it's a must and right now
we are far from it guys okay we are very
far from it the 20-week moving average
is at 51 000 so this is the reason why
i'm telling you 52 51 55 is the area of
resistance so
if we don't go above that level
it's for sure a b wave okay but i mean
if we correct then it's easy to say it
was a b wave but if we go across that
level with very high volume then maybe
maybe it's a fifth wave two hundred
thousand that is starting so two
information look at the volume look at
the 20 week moving average look at the
52 000 level and last thing guys
volatility so the volatility is the
measure of the amplitude of the moves it
gives us indication about if traders are
trading you know if there are big moves
in the market it's uh an information
about the confidence of investors
that you know just buy a lot so that or
sell a lot if there is panic so we just
add the body jobs yes that's the best
indicator to look at that and we can
just check
how were the bollinger bands between the
first wave and we can see that
here they were tight but we you see here
there were tights during the first wave
here very tight breakout above this
bollinger upper band so during the b
wave it didn't happen during the b wave
it didn't happen during here the first
wave it didn't happen but it happened
during the third wave and they were
basically tightening all right and right
now they're widening on the weekly
timeframe which tells us that whatever
happens we need time all right so i do
either we do an abc or a one two that
will take some time so no rush guys
don't buy at 52 because we're gonna see
even if there is a huge move up there
will probably be a pullback around the
42 45 000 area in two three months so we
have really a lot of time we don't need
to form on the upside and if we zoom in
and check on the daily time frame we can
see as well look guys during this
rebound that happened
in july 21 they were very tight all
right before the rebound if you just
follow the tightness of the bollinger
band you can see here they are very wide
so when they are very wide on the
deletion frame it's not we're not even
talking about a small time frame b wave
and right now on the dirty time frame
that's still widening which tells us
that there is still panic in this market
that the moves are too big for a
sustainable reversal to happen so once
again the conclusion is that first we
have time we're gonna see probably low
levels happening again
later even if we have a breakout above
42 above 40 000 uh 40 000 is the level
to watch on the short term to know if
maybe we start a first wave or a b wave
the first wave will involve huge volume
guys uh whereas a b wave would probably
be involve weak volume and probably not
cross the 20-week moving average so
that's it for me guys i hope you enjoyed
this video and if you did please don't
forget to click on the sub like and bell
button and for those who are interested
to get the course click on the link to
subscribe to my website and you will
receive
the information about when the course is
coming so thank you very much guys and i
see you soon